The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, for
the last two lectures
we've been talking about
analyzing algorithms,
complexity, orders of growth.
How do we estimate the
cost of an algorithm
as the size of the input grows?
And as I've said
several times, I'll
say at least once
more, how do we also
turn it the other direction?
How do we use thoughts about
choices of pieces of algorithm
in terms of
implications on the cost
it's going to take
us to compute?
We saw last time a set of
examples-- constant algorithms,
linear algorithms, logarithmic
algorithms, linear algorithms,
quadratic algorithms,
exponential algorithms.
Today, what I'm
going to do is fill
in one more piece, a log linear
algorithm-- something that's
really a nice kind of algorithm
to have-- and use it to talk
about one last class
of algorithms that
are really valuable, and those
are searching and sorting
algorithms.
So a search algorithm.
Kind of an obvious statement.
You use them all the time
when you go to Google or Bing
or whatever your favorite
search mechanism on the web is.
It's just a way to find an
item or a group of items
from a collection.
If you think about
it, that collection
could be either
implicit or explicit.
So way back at the
beginning of the term,
we saw an example of
a search algorithm
when you were looking
for square roots.
And we saw simple things
like exhaustive enumeration.
We'd go through all
the possibilities.
We saw our first version
of bisection search
there, where you would
do approximations.
Newton-Raphson-- these are all
examples of a search algorithm
where the collection
is implicit.
So all the numbers between some
point that some other point.
More common is a
search algorithm
where the collection
is explicit.
I don't know.
For example, I've got all
the data records of students
and I want to know how do I
find a particular student,
so I can record that A plus
that everybody in this room
is going to get next
Tuesday on that exam?
That's not a promise.
Sorry.
But we'll work on it.
So could do it implicit,
could do it explicit.
Today I want to focus on
doing search explicitly.
And it could be on different
kinds of collections,
but I'm going to focus-- just
as an example-- on search
over lists.
And to make it a little
easier, let's just do search
over lists of numbers.
But it could obviously be
other kinds of elements.
Now you've already seen
some of this, right?
We did search where we said,
we can do linear search.
Brute force.
Just walk down the list
looking at everything
till we either find the
thing we're looking for
or we get to the
end of the list.
Sometimes also called
British Museum algorithm
or exhaustive enumeration.
I go through
everything in the list.
Nice news is, the list
doesn't have to be sorted.
It could be just
in arbitrary order.
What we saw is that the
expected-- sorry, not expected.
The worst case
behavior is linear.
In the worst case, the
element's not in the list.
I got to look at everything.
So it's going to be linear
in terms of complexity.
And then we looked
at bisection search,
where we said the list
needs to be sorted.
But if it is, we can actually
be much more efficient
because we can take advantage
of the sorting to cut down
the size of the problem.
And I'll remind you
about both of those.
There was our simple
little linear search.
Right?
Set a flag that says,
I haven't yet found it.
And then just loop over
the indices into the list.
I could have also just
looped directly over the list
itself, checking to see if
the ith member of the list
is the thing I'm looking for.
If it is, change
the flag to true
so that when I come
out of all of this
I'll return the flag--
either false because it
was set that way initially
or true because I found it.
And of course what we knew is
we have to look at everything
to see if it's there or not.
I could speed this up by just
returning true at this point.
While that would improve
the average case,
doesn't improve the worst case.
And that's the thing we
usually are concerned about,
because in the worst case I've
got to go through everything.
And just to remind
you, we said this
is order length of the list.
To go around this
part-- the loop right
here-- and inside the
loop, it's constant work.
I'm doing the same number
of things each time.
That's order n times order 1.
And by our rules,
that's just order n.
So it's linear in the
size of the problem.
OK.
We said we could do
it on sorted lists.
But just again, we'll
walk down the list.
Again, here I could loop
over everything in the list,
checking to see if
it's the thing I want.
Return true.
And if I ever get to a point
where the element of the list
is bigger than the
thing I'm looking for,
I know it can't be in
the rest of the list
because all the things to
the right are bigger yet.
I could just Return
false and drop out.
In terms of average
behavior, this
is better because
it's going to stop
as soon as it gets
to a point where it
can rule everything else out.
But in terms of complexity,
it's still order n.
Because I still on average
have-- not average.
In the worst case,
I'm still going
to be looking n times
through the loop
before I get to a point where
I can decide to bail out of it.
So order n.
And then finally-- last piece
of recap-- bisection search.
Repeat again.
The idea here is, take
the midpoint of the list.
Look at that element.
If it's the thing I'm
looking for, great.
I just won the lottery.
If it isn't, decide
is the thing I'm
looking for bigger or less
than that middle point.
If it's bigger than that, I only
use the upper half of the list.
If it's less than that, I only
use the lower half of the list.
And the characteristic
here was, at each step,
I'm reducing the size
of the problem in half.
I'm throwing away half of the
remaining list at each step.
And I'll just remind
you of that code.
I know it's a lot here,
but just to remind you.
It said, down here if
I've got an empty list,
it can't be there.
I'm going to Return false.
Otherwise call this
little helper function
with the list, the thing
for which I'm searching,
and the beginning and end
point indices into the list.
Initially the start
and the very end.
And this code up
here basically says,
if those two numbers are the
same I'm down to a list of one.
Just check to see if it's
the thing I'm looking for.
Otherwise, pick something
halfway in between.
And ignore this
case for the moment.
Basically then check
to see, is the thing
at that point bigger than e?
In which case, I'm
in general going
to call this only with from
the low point to the midpoint.
Otherwise I'm going to call
this with the midpoint to high.
And that was just this
idea of, keep cutting down
in half the size of the list.
Last piece of the
recap-- the thing
we wanted you to see here--
is there are the two recursive
calls.
I'm only going to do one
because I'm making a decision.
At each step, I'm cutting
down the problem by half.
And that says the number of
steps, the number of times
I'm going to iterate
through here,
will be log in the
length of the list.
And if that still doesn't
make sense to you, it says,
I need to know when 1
over 2 to the k-- where
k is the number of
steps-- is equal to 1.
Because in each step,
I'm reducing by half.
And that's when k
is log base 2 of n.
So that's why it's log linear.
And so this just reminds you.
Again, that recap.
Number of calls
reduced-- or, sorry.
The call gets reduced by
a factor or two each time.
I'm going to have a log
n work going around it.
And inside it's a
constant amount of work
because I'm just
passing the pointers,
I'm not actually
copying the list.
And that's a nice state to be.
OK, so-- sounds good.
Could just use linear search.
It's going to be linear.
When you use binary search
or bisection search,
we can do it in log time.
That's great.
We assumed the list was
sorted, but all right.
So that lens basically says, OK.
So when does it make
sense to sort the list
and then do the search?
Right?
Because if I can sort
the list cheaply,
then the search is
going to be logarithmic.
That's really what I would like.
This little expression
basically says,
let's let sort be the
cost of sorting the list.
I want to know when that cost
plus something that's order
log n-- which is what it's going
to cost me to do this search.
When is that less than
something that's order n?
Because then it's going to be
better to do the sort first
than do the search.
And so I can just rearrange it.
It needs to be, when does the
cost of sorting-- when is it
last than this expression?
Which basically
says, when is sorting
going to be less expensive
than the linear cost?
Crud.
Actually, good news
for you, right?
This is a really short lecture.
Because it says it's never true.
Ouch.
Don't worry.
We've got more to
go on the lecture.
The reason it can't be
true-- if you think about it
just informally-- is, if I've
got a collection of n elements
and I want to sort
it, I've got to look
at each one of those
elements at least once.
Right?
I have to look at them
to decide where they go.
Oh, that's n elements.
So sorting must be
at least order n,
because I got to
look at everything.
And in fact as it
says there, I'm
going to have to use at least
linear time to do the sort.
Sounds like we're
stuck, but we're not.
And the reason is,
often when I want
to search something I'm going
to do multiple searches,
but I may only want
to sort the list once.
In fact, I probably only
want to sort the list once.
So in that case, I'm
spreading out the cost.
I'm amortizing the
expense of the sort.
And now what I want to know is,
if I'm going to do k searches,
the cost of those
k searches I know
is going to be k log n-- because
it's log to do the search.
And I simply need
to know, is the cost
of sorting plus
this-- can I have
something where it's less
than k searches just using
linear search?
And the answer is, yes.
There are going to be,
for large k's, ways
in which we can do the sort
where the sort time becomes
irrelevant, that
the cost is really
dominated by this search.
And so what I want to do
now is look at-- all right.
How could we do the sort
reasonably efficiently?
It's going to have to
be at least linear.
We're going to see it's going
to be a little more than linear.
But if I could do it reasonably,
I'm going to be in good shape
here.
So what I want to do is show
you a number of ways in which we
can do sorting-- take
a list of elements
and sort them from, in this
case, smaller to higher
or increasing order.
So here's my goal.
I want to efficiently
sort a list.
I want to see if we can do this
as efficiently as possible.
I'm going to start,
you might say,
with a humorous version of sort.
You're all convinced that
my humor is non-existent.
You're right.
But it sets the stage for it.
This is a sort.
You can look it up.
It's called monkey sort, BOGO
sort, stupid sort, slow sort,
permutation sort, shotgun sort.
And here's how it works.
Anna has nicely given me a
set of numbers on cards here.
Here's how you do BOGO sort.
I got to do that better.
I got to spread them
out randomly, like this.
Oh good.
I'm going to have
to-- sorry, Tom.
I'm not walking.
And now I pick them up,
saying, is that less than this?
Which is less than-- oh, crud.
They're not sorted.
All right.
I pick them all up
and I do it again.
A little brain damage, right?
Now it's intended to
get your attention.
I did.
I heard a couple of chuckles.
Those are A
students, by the way.
I heard a couple
of chuckles here.
We could actually do
this exhaustively.
Basically it's called
permutation sort
because you could search through
all possible permutations
to see if you find
something that's sorted.
That, by the way--
the complexity of that
is something like n
factorial, which for large n
is n to the nth power.
And if n's anything bigger
than about 2, don't do it.
Right?
But it would be a way to
think about doing this.
All right.
Now, having caught the humorous
version of this, how could
we do this a little bit better?
Oh sorry.
I should say, what's
the complexity?
There's a nice crisp
definition of BOGO sort.
Its best case is order
n, because I just
need to check it's sorted.
Its average case is n
factorial and its worst case,
if I'm just doing it
randomly, is God knows.
Because I could be
doing it here forever.
So we're going to move on.
Here's a second way to
do it called bubble sort.
I'm going to do this with
a small version of this.
I'm going to put out a set.
I'll turn these up so you
can see them in a second.
The idea of bubble
sort is, I'm going
to start at-- I'm going to call
this the front end of the list.
And I'm going to walk down,
comparing elements pairwise.
And I'm always going to
move the larger one over.
So I start here and I
say, 1 is less than 11.
I'm OK.
11's bigger than five.
I'm going to bubble that up.
11's bigger than 6.
11's bigger than 2.
I've basically
bubbled 11 to the end.
Now I go back here.
I say, 1 is less than 5.
That's good.
5 is less than 6.
Ah, 6 is bigger than 2.
Bubble that.
6 is less than 11.
You get the idea-- comparison,
comparison, and swap.
Comparison, comparison.
And now if I go back
to this part and do it,
you'll notice that's
in the right order.
That's in the right order.
I'm done.
Small round of applause, please.
I was able to sort
five elements.
Thank you.
The little video is
showing the same thing.
You can see the idea here.
It's called bubble
sort because you're
literally bubbling things
up to the end of the list.
It's pretty simple to do.
You're just swapping pairs.
And as you saw, when I
get to the end of the list
I go back and do it
until I have a pass where
I go all the way through the
list and I don't do any swaps.
And in that case I know I'm done
because everything's in order,
and I can stop.
One of the properties of it
is that the largest unsorted
element is always at
the end after the pass.
In other words,
after the first one
I know that the largest
element's at the end.
After the second one,
the largest thing left
is going to be in
the next place.
And that tells me,
among other things,
that this is going to
take no more than n times
through the list to succeed.
It might actually
take fewer than that.
OK.
Again let's look at
some code for it.
Let's look at its complexity
and let's actually run this.
So here is a little simple
version of bubble sort.
I'm going to set a flag up here.
I'm going to call its
swap initially to false.
That's going to let
me tell when I'm
done, when I've gone through
everything in the list
without doing a swap.
And then I'm going to loop.
As long as swap is false-- so
the first time through it's
going to do that loop.
I set swap initially to true,
and notice what I then do.
I let j range from 1 up
to the length of the list,
and I look at the jth element
and the previous element.
If the previous element is
bigger, I'm going to flip them.
Right there.
And that's just doing that
swap, what I just did down here.
And if that's the case, I'm
going to set the flag to false.
Which says, I've done at least
one bubble as part of this.
Which means when
I come out of here
and go back around to the loop,
it's going to do it again.
And it will do it
until all of this
succeeds without this ever
being true, in which case
that's true, which
makes that false.
And it will drop out.
OK?
Let's look at an
example of this running.
It's just to give
you a sense of that,
assuming I can find
the right place here.
So there is, again, a version
of bubble sort on the side.
And I'm going to bring this
down to the bottom I've
got a little test list there.
And I've put a print
statement in it.
So you can see each
time through the loop,
what's the form of
the list as it starts.
And assuming I've done
this right-- here you go.
There's the list the
first time through.
Notice after one pass, 25's
at the end of the list--
the biggest element.
Exactly what I like.
But you can also see a few
other things have flipped.
Right?
Right in there, there
have been some other swaps
as it bubbled through.
And in fact, you can see it's--
well, you can see that idea.
You can see 25 moving through.
Notice on the next step,
a whole bunch of the list
is actually in the right order.
It's just because I got lucky.
All I can guarantee is
that the second largest
element is the second
from the end of the list.
But you can see here.
Even though the
list is, I think,
nine long, it only took
us four passes through.
So this is nice.
It says, at most, n
times through the list.
And at the end, we
actually get out
something that's
in the right form.
OK.
So let's go back to
this and basically say,
what's the complexity?
Well that's length n, right?
Has to be.
I'm going through
the entire list.
And inside of there
is just constant work.
Four operations.
I'm doing a test.
Sorry, five.
And then depending whether
that test is true or not,
I'm setting a flag and doing
some movement of things around.
But it's just constant.
I don't care about the five.
And there, how many times
do I go around the loop?
In the worst case, n.
All I can guarantee is,
after the first pass
the biggest thing is here.
After the second pass, the
second biggest thing is there.
After the third pass--
you get the idea.
So I've got order and
things inside the loop,
and I'm doing that loop n times.
And I hope that looks familiar.
We've talked about this.
Right?
This is nested loops.
What's this?
Quadratic.
So it's order n squared, where
n is the length of the list.
Now as you also saw, on average,
it could be less than that.
But it's going to
be order n squared.
OK.
That's one possibility.
Here's a second nice,
simple, sort algorithm.
It's called selection sort.
You can kind of think of
this as going the other way.
Not completely, but
going the other way.
And when I say
going the other way,
the idea here is that I'm
going to find the smallest
element in the list.
And I'm going to stick it
at the front of the list
when I'm done, and simply
swap that place with whatever
was there.
Flip them.
I might do a few other
flips along the way,
depending how I implement this.
Next, pass.
I'm just going to
look at everything
but the first element, because
I know that one's done.
I'm going to do the same thing.
Find the smallest element
remaining in the list,
put it in the second
spot, and keep doing that.
What I know is, if I
implement this correctly,
after i steps the first
i elements of the list
will be sorted.
And everything in
the rest of the list
has to be bigger than
the largest thing
in the first part of the list.
OK.
So we could build that.
Before we do it, I'm going
to show you a little video
starring Professor Guttag.
This is his cameo
performance here.
But I want to just show
you an example of this
using not numbers, but people.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- All right.
So now we're going
to do selection sort.
The idea here is
that each step we're
going to select
the shortest person
and put them next in
line of the sorted group.
So we'll bring the
leftmost person forward,
and we will compare
her to everybody else.
So one at a time, step forward.
You're still the winner.
You go back.
Please step forward.
PROFESSOR: And watch the number
of comparisons that go on,
by the way.
We're going to
come back to that.
- Next.
Still the winner.
Next.
Ah.
A new winner.
All right.
So you can take her place.
PROFESSOR: So here, we're
choosing to actually insert
into the spot in
the Line We could
have put her back at the front,
but either one will work.
- Now we'll compare.
Same old winner.
Same winner.
No change.
It's getting kind of boring.
Don't fall, that-- same winner.
Please.
PROFESSOR: This is a tough one.
- Oh.
Close, but I think
you're still shorter.
All right.
Next.
No change, which means
you are the first in line.
Congratulations.
PROFESSOR: So, smallest element
now going to be the first slot.
- Now you step forward,
and we'll compare you.
PROFESSOR: I would
invite you to watch
the left hand of the list.
Notice how it is slowly
building up at each stage
to have that portion sorted.
And we deliberately
admit students
to be of different heights,
so John can do this demo.
- You are the winner.
Take your place in line.
Next.
It's you.
And once again, we
have a lovely group
of students sorted
in height order.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: And
check out-- I want
you to remember number
of comparisons-- 55.
Not that the [INAUDIBLE], but
I want you to see a comparison
as we go on in a second.
So again, selection sort.
This is this idea of,
find the smallest element.
Put it at the front.
I might do a little
number of flips,
as you can see,
here along the way.
But this is the same
animation of that.
So let's first of all
convince ourselves
it will do the right thing,
and then look at some code,
and then run the code.
So to convince
ourselves that this
is going to do the
right thing, we
could talk about something that
we often refer to as a loop
invariant.
We're going to write
a loop, but we're
going to walk through this.
And the invariant
here-- and we want
to just demonstrate if
it's true at the beginning
and it's true at each step.
Therefore, by induction
as we did earlier,
I can conclude it's true always.
Is that if I'm given the
prefix or the first part
of a list from 0 up to i,
and a suffix or a second part
of the list from i plus 1 up to
the end of the overall list--
given that, then I want to
assert that the invariant is
that the prefix is sorted
and no element of the prefix
is larger than the smallest
element of the suffix.
Just what I said earlier.
It says, at any stage here--
if this is the amount of sort
I've done so far-- I can
guarantee, I'm going to claim,
this will be sorted.
And everything here is
bigger than that thing there.
How do I prove it?
Well the base case
is really easy.
In the base case,
the prefix is empty.
I don't have anything,
so it's obviously sorted.
And everything in
the suffix is bigger
than anything in the prefix.
So I'm fine.
And then I just want to say,
as long as I write my code so
that this step is true, then
I'm going to move the smallest
element from the suffix--
the second part of the list--
to the end of the prefix.
Since the prefix was
sorted, this is now sorted.
And everything in
the suffix is still
going to be bigger than
everything in the prefix.
And as a consequence,
by induction,
this is going to give me
something that says it's always
going to be correct.
So here's code
that would do that.
Here.
I'm just going to set a
little thing called the start
of suffix, or soft start.
Initially it's going to point
to the beginning of the list.
And then I'm going
to run a loop.
And as long as I
still have things
to search in the list,
that that pointer doesn't
point to the end of the
list, what am I going to do?
I'm going to loop
over everything
from that point to
the end of the list,
comparing it to the
thing at that point.
If it's less than,
I'm going to do a swap
because I wanted to move it up.
And you can see,
by the time I get
through this loop I will have
found the smallest element
in the remainder of the list.
And I would have put it
at that spot, whatever
suffix start points to.
And when I've done all of that,
I just change this by one.
Having found the
smallest element,
I've stuck it at spot zero.
I'll do the same thing.
Having found the next
smallest element,
I know it's at point one.
And I'll just continue around.
One of the things
you can see here
is, as opposed to
bubble sort, this one
is going to take n
times around the loop
because I'm only moving
this pointer by one
So it starts at 0, and then
1, and then 2, all the way up
to n minus 1.
You can also see in this
particular implementation,
while I'm certainly ensuring
that the smallest element goes
into that spot, I may do a
few other flips along the way.
I'm going to find something I
think is the smallest element,
put it there and put
that element here.
And then when I find
another smaller element,
I may do that flip.
I could have implemented
this where I literally
search for the smallest
element and only move that.
Doesn't make any difference
in terms of the complexity.
All right.
What's the complexity here?
Already said this part.
I will loop n times, because
I start at 0 and then 1.
You get the idea.
Inside of the loop
I'm going to walk down
the remainder of the list,
which is initially n.
And then n minus 1, and
then n minus 2 times.
But we've seen that
before as well.
While they get shorter, that
complexity is still quadratic.
Order n times going
through this process.
Within the process, order n
things that I have to compare.
And yes, n gets smaller.
But we know that that n term,
if you like to dominate.
So again, this is quadratic.
OK.
Before you believe that
all sorting algorithms are
quadratic, I want to
show you the last one,
the one that actually is
one of the-- I think--
the prettiest algorithms
around, and a great example
of a more efficient algorithm.
It's called merge sort.
Merge sort takes an
approach we've seen before.
We talked about
divide and conquer.
Break the problem down
into smaller versions
of the same problem.
And once you've got
those solutions,
bring the answer back together.
For merge sort,
that's pretty easy.
It says, if I've got a list of
0 or 1 elements, it's sorted.
Duh.
OK.
If I got a list of more than
1 element, here's my trick.
I'm going to split
it into two lists.
I'm going to sort them.
And when I'm done, I'm just
going to merge those two lists
into one list.
And the merge is easy.
Because if I've got two
lists that are sorted,
I just need to look at
the first element of each,
take the one that's smaller.
Add it to my result. And
keep doing that until one
of the lists is empty.
And then just copy the
remainder of the other list.
You can probably
already get a sense
of what the cost is going
to be here, because this
is cutting the problem in half.
Now I've got two pieces.
So I need to think
about both of them.
I want to give you a couple
of visualizations of this.
Here's the first one.
It says, basically, I've
got a big unsorted list.
I'm going to split it.
And I'm going to split it.
Until I get down to just lists
that are either 0 or 1, which
by definition are sorted.
And once I'm at that
level, then I just
have to merge them
into a sorted list
and then merge them
pairwise into a sorted list.
And you get the idea.
So it's divide and conquer.
The divide is dividing it
up into smaller pieces.
The conquer is merging
them back together.
And we have Professor
Guttag back for an encore,
together with his students.
So let's show you an
example of merge sort.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So we're about to
demonstrate merge sort.
And we're going to sort this
rather motley collection of MIT
students by height.
So the first thing
we need to do is,
we're going to ask everyone
to split into a group of two.
So you split a little bit.
You two are together.
And you are all by yourself.
I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: Poor Anna.
- All right.
So now let's take
the first group.
Take a step down.
And what we do is, we
sort this group by height,
with the shortest on the left.
And look at this.
We don't have to do anything.
Thank you.
Feel free to go back up.
We then sort the next pair.
Please.
And it looks to me
like we need to switch.
All right.
Take a step back.
Ladies-- OK.
Ladies, gentlemen-- also OK.
And again, OK.
PROFESSOR: Notice each
subgroup is now sorted.
Which is great.
- And I think you're
in the correct order.
Now what we do is, we take these
groups and merge the groups.
So let's have these two--
going to sort these groups,
have them step forward.
And now what we're
doing is, we're
doing a merge of the
two sorted groups.
So we start by merging them.
We'll take the leftmost
person in this group
and compare her to the
first person in this group,
and decide.
She's still the shortest.
Take a step back.
Now we're going to
look at you and say,
you're actually taller
than this fellow.
So you now step up there.
And we're good here.
Both of you take a step back.
Now we'll take these two groups
and follow the same procedure.
We'll merge them.
Let's see.
We'll compare you--
the first person
in this group to the first
person in this group.
Now it's a little tricky.
So let's see, the
two of you compare.
Let's see, back to back.
We have a winner.
Step back.
And now we need to compare the
shortest person in this group
to the shortest
person in this group.
We have a winner.
It's you.
I'm sorry.
And now we just-- we're OK.
Please step back.
Now we'll have these
two groups come forward.
We'll compare the shortest
person in this group
to the shortest
person in that group.
I actually need you guys
to get back to back here.
You are the winner.
And it's pretty clear that the
shortest person in this group
is shorter than the shortest
person in that group.
So you go there
and you step back.
PROFESSOR: Notice the groups.
Now all sorted.
- And now we repeat
the same process.
PROFESSOR: And notice how
the whole subgroup now
goes up once we know
that one group is empty.
- And you can see that we
have a group of students
sorted in order by height.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Remember the
first number, right?
55, 28.
Now it's just
numbers but you can
see the expectation is, this
is going to take less time.
And it certainly did there.
So again just to demo
another way visually.
I'm sorting-- sorry.
I am splitting down
until I get small things,
and then just merging them up.
I may have to do multiple
passes through here,
but it's going to
be hopefully faster
than the other
methods we looked at.
I'm going to show
you code in a second,
and then we're going to
run it just to see it.
But let me stress one more
time just the idea of merging.
You can see the idea.
I keep splitting down till I
got something small enough.
And I want to merge them back.
The idea of merging-- you've
seen it from Professor Guttag.
But I just want to highlight why
this is going to be efficient.
If I've got two lists:
list 1 and list 2,
the things left there.
Process is very simple.
I pull out the smallest
element of each.
I compare them.
And I simply put the
smallest one into the result,
move on in that first list.
So the 1 disappears
from that left list.
And now again I pull up just the
smallest element of each one,
do the comparison.
Smallest one goes to
the end of my result.
And I drop that
element from its list.
So I've now taken 1 from
list 1 and one from list 2.
You get the idea.
The reason I want to give you
this visualization-- sorry.
Let me do the last step.
Once I get to a place where
one of the lists is empty,
just copy the rest of
the list onto the end.
You can see already
a hint of the code.
And that is, that I'm
only going to ever look
at each element of each
sublist once as I do the merge.
And that's a nice property.
Having had them
sorted, I don't need
to do lots of
interior comparisons.
I'm only comparing
the ends of the list.
I only, therefore,
look at each element--
the number of comparisons,
rather, I should say.
I may look at each
element more than once.
The number of
comparisons is going
to be, at most, the number
of elements in both lists.
And that's going to
be a nice Q as we
think about how to solve it.
So here's the code to merge,
and then we'll write Merge Sort.
And I know there's
a lot of code here,
but we can walk through it
and get a good sense of it.
I'm going to set up a
variable called Result that's
going to hold my answer.
And I'm going to set up
two indices, i and j, that
are initially 0.
They're pointing
to the beginning.
And remember, the
input here is two lists
that we know are sorted--
or should be sorted,
or we screwed up in some way.
So initially, i and j are
both pointing to the beginning
of the left and right list.
And look at what we do.
We say, as long as there's
still something in the left list
and still something
in the right list-- i
is less than the
length of left, j
length of right.
Do the comparison.
If the left wants smaller,
add it to the end of result.
To the end of result, right?
I'm appending it because I want
it to be in that sorted order.
And increase i.
If it's not, add the right
one to the end of result
and increase j.
And I'll just keep
doing that until I
exhaust one of the lists.
And when I do I
can basically say,
if the right list is empty,
I know if I get out of here
they can't both be true.
In other words, if there's still
something in the left list,
just put it on the end.
Otherwise if the only things
left are in the right list,
just put them on the end.
So I'm just walking down the
list, doing the comparison,
adding the smallest element to
my result. And when I'm done,
I just return result.
Complexity we can already
begin to see here, right?
This says the left and
right sublists are ordered,
so I'm just moving the
indices depending on which
one holds the smaller element.
And when I get done, I'm just
returning the rest of the list.
So what's the complexity here?
I'm going to do this a
little more informally.
You could actually do
that kind of relationship
I did last time.
But what am I doing?
I'm going through the two
lists, but only one time
through each of those two lists.
I'm only comparing
the smallest elements.
So as I already said, this says
that the number of elements
I copy will be everything in
the left list and everything
in the right list.
So that order is just
the length of left
plus the length of right.
And how many
comparisons do I do?
The most I have to do is however
many are in the longer list.
Right?
That's the maximum
number I need to have.
Oh, that's nice.
That says, if the lists are
of order n-- I'm doing order n
copies, because
order n plus order
n is just 2n, which
is order n-- then
I'm doing order n comparisons.
So it's linear in the
length of the lists.
OK.
Sounds good.
That just does the merge.
How do I do merge sort?
Well we said it.
Break the problem in half.
Keep doing it until
I get sorted lists.
And then grow them back up.
So there's merge sort.
It says, if the list is
either empty or of length 1,
just return a copy of the list.
It's sorted.
Otherwise find
the middle point--
there's that integer
division-- and split.
Split the list everything
up to the middle point
and do merge sort on that.
Split everything in the list
from the middle point on.
Do merge sort on that.
And when I get back those two
sorted lists, just merge them.
Again, I hope you can see
what the order of growth
should be here.
Cutting the problem down
in half at each step.
So the number of times I
should have to go through this
should be to log n the
size of the original list.
And you can see why we
call it divide and conquer.
I'm dividing it down
into small pieces
until I have a simple
solution and then
I'm growing that
solution back up.
So there is the base
case, there's the divide,
and there's the nice conquer
[INAUDIBLE] piece of this.
OK.
I'm going to show you
an example of that.
But let's actually look at
some code-- sorry about that.
Let's look at some
code to do this.
And in fact I meant to do
this earlier and didn't.
I also have a version
of bubble sort here.
Sorry-- selection sort.
I've already done bubble sort.
There is selection sort.
Let's uncomment this.
And let's run both
of those and just see
the comparison between them.
Yeah, sorry-- just make that
a little easier to read.
There we go.
So we saw a bubble sort.
It only went through four
times, so less than n times.
There's selection sort.
And as I said to
you, it has to do
n passes it because it can only
ever guarantee that it gets
one element at the beginning.
So you can in fact see, in
this case, from the first
or after the initial input
until the end of the first step,
it looks like it
didn't do anything
because it determined eventually
that one was in the right spot.
And similarly I think
there's another one
right there where
it doesn't do any--
or appears not to do anything.
All it's guaranteeing is
that the next smallest
element is in the right spot.
As we get through
to the end of it,
it in fact ends up
in the right place.
And then let's
look at merge sort
and do one more
visualization of this.
Again let me remove that.
If we run it-- again, I've
just put some print statements
in there.
Here you can see
a nice behavior.
I start off calling
Merge Sort with that,
which splits down into doing
Merge Sort of this portion.
Eventually it's going to
come back down there and do
the second one.
It keeps doing it until it
gets down to simple lists
that it knows are sorted.
And then it merges it.
Does the smaller pieces
and then merges it.
And having now 2
merged things, it
can do the next level of merge.
So you can see that it gets
this nice reduction of problems
until it gets down
to the smallest size.
So let's just look at one
more visualization of that
and then get the complexity.
So if I start out with this
list-- sorry about that.
What I need to do is split it.
Take the first one, split it.
Keep doing that until I
get down to a base case
where I know what those are
and I simply merge them.
Pass it back up.
Take the second piece.
Split it until I get
down to base cases.
Do the merge, which
is nice and linear.
Pass that back up.
Having done those two
pieces, I do one more merge.
And I do the same thing.
I want you to see
this, because again you
can notice how many
levels in this tree log.
Log in the size.
Because at each stage
here, I went from a problem
of 8 to two problems of 4.
Each of those went
to two problems of 2,
and each of those went to
two problems of size 1.
All right.
So the last piece is,
what's the complexity?
Here's a simple way
to think about it.
At the top level, I start
off with n elements.
I've got two sorted
lists of size n over 2.
And to merge them together,
I need to do order n work.
Because as I said I got to do
at least n comparisons where
n is the length of the list.
And then I've got to do n plus
n copies, which is just order n.
So I'm doing order n work.
At the second level, it gets
a little more complicated.
Now I've got problems
of size n over 4.
But how many of them do I have?
4.
Oh, that's nice.
Because what do I
know about this?
I know that I have to copy
each element at least once.
So not at least once.
I will copy each
element exactly once.
And I'll do comparisons
that are equal to the length
of the longer list.
So I've got four sublists
of length n over 4
that says n elements.
That's nice.
Order n.
At each step, the
subproblems get smaller
but I have more of them.
But the total size
of the problem is n.
So the cost at each
step is order n.
How many times do I do it?
Log n.
So this is log n iterations
with order n work at each step.
And this is a wonderful example
of a log linear algorithm.
It's n log n, where n is
the length of the list.
So what you end up with, then,
is-- all right, a joke version,
some reasonable
ways of doing sort
that are quick and easy to
implement but are quadratic,
and then an elegant way of
doing the search that's n log n.
And I'll remind you I started
by saying, as long as I
can make the cost of
sorting small enough
I can amortize that cost.
And if you go back and look
at last lecture's notes,
you'll see n log n
grows pretty slowly.
And it's actually
a nice thing to do.
It makes it reasonable
to do the sort.
And then I can do the
search in order n time.
And here's the last punchline.
It's the fastest we can do.
I'm going to look at John again.
I don't think anybody has
found a faster sort algorithm.
Right?
This is the best one can do.
Unless you do-- sorry,
the best worst case.
I'm sorry.
John is absolute right.
There are better average cases.
Again, our concern
is worst case.
So this is as good
as we're going
to do in terms of a
worst case algorithm.
So there you now have sorting
algorithms and searching
algorithms, and
you've now seen--
excuse me, sorry--
constant, log, linear,
log linear, quadratic, and
exponential algorithms.
I'll remind you, we
want things as high up
in that hierarchy as possible.
All right.
I have six minutes left.
Some of you are
going to leave us.
We're going to miss
you, but that's OK.
I'm sure we'll see later on.
For those of you hanging around,
this isn't a bad time just
to step back and say,
so what have we seen?
And I want to do this
just very quickly.
I'm sorry.
And I'll remind you, we started
by in some sense giving you
a little bit of a
contract of things
we were going to show you.
And I would simply suggest
to you, what have we done?
We've given you a sense of
how to represent knowledge
with data structures, tuples,
lists, dictionaries, more
complicated structures.
We've shown you some good
computational metaphors,
iteration, and loops.
Recursion has a great way
of breaking problems down
into simpler versions
of the same problem.
And there really are metaphors.
There are ways of
thinking about problems.
We've given you abstraction, the
idea of capture a computation,
bury it in a procedure.
You now have a contract.
You don't need to know what
happens inside the procedure
as long as it delivers the
answer it says it would.
Or another way of saying
it, you can delegate it
to somebody and trust
that you're going
to get what you like out of it.
We've seen classes and
methods as a wonderful way
to modularize systems,
to capture combinations
of data and things that operate
on them in a nice, elegant way.
And we just spent
a week and a half
talking about
classes of algorithms
and their complexity.
If you step up a level, what we
hope you've gotten out of this
are a couple of things.
You've begun to learn
computational modes
of thinking.
How do I tackle a problem
and divide and conquer?
How do I think about
recursion as a tool
in dealing with something?
You've begun to-- begun, I will
use that word deliberately--
to master the art of
computational problem solving.
How can you take a problem
and turn it into an algorithm?
And especially, you've
begun to have the ability
to make the computer
do what you want it to.
To say, if I've got a problem
from biology or chemistry
or math or physics or
chemical engineering
or mechanical engineering, how
do I take that problem and say,
here's how I would
design an algorithm
to give me a simulation and a
way of evaluating what it does.
And so what we
hope we've done is,
we've started you down the path
to being able to think and act
like a computer scientist.
All right.
Don't panic.
That doesn't mean you
stare at people's shoes
when you talk to them.
Not all computer scientists
do that, just faculty.
Sorry, John.
So what do computer
scientists do?
And this is actually
meant to be serious.
And I put up two of my
famous historical figures
of computer scientists.
They do think computationally.
They think about abstractions,
about algorithms,
about automated execution.
So the three A's of
computational thinking.
And in the same way
that traditionally you
had the three R's of reading,
writing, and arithmetic,
computational thinking we
hope is becoming a fundamental
that every well-educated
person is going to need.
And that says, you think
about the right abstraction.
When you have a problem
in your [INAUDIBLE]
what's the right abstraction?
How do I pull apart the pieces?
How do I think about that in
terms of decomposing things
into a relationship that I
can use to solve problems?
How do I automate?
How do I mechanize
that abstraction?
How do I use what I know
happens inside of the machine
to write a sequence of
steps in a language I'm
using to capture that process?
And then finally, how do I
turn that into an algorithm?
And that not only means I
need a language for describing
those automated
processes, and if you
like allowing the
abstraction of details,
but frankly also a
way to communicate.
If you have to think
crisply about how do I
describe an algorithm,
it's actually
giving you a way to
crystallize or clarify
your thinking about a problem.
This is not to say you should
talk to your friends in Python.
I don't recommend it.
But it does say you
should use that thinking
as a way of capturing your ideas
of what you're going to do.
And that leads, then,
to this idea of,
how difficult is a problem?
How best can I solve it?
We've shown you these
complexity classes
and we've hinted at the idea
that in fact some problems
are inherently more
difficult than others.
That's something I hope you
come back to as you go along.
And especially we want you to
start thinking recursively.
We want you to think about
how do I take a hard problem,
break it up into simpler
versions of the same problem,
and then construct the solution.
And that shows up
lots of places.
Right?
Recursion is in all sorts
of wonderful places.
So just to give you an example,
I could say to you recursively,
"This lecture will
end when I'm done
talking about this
lecture, which
will end when I'm done talking
about this lecture, which
will end when I'm done--"
All right.
You don't like
infinite recursion.
Good luck on the exam.